welcome to episode 2 of opposing views
this one is opposing views on abortion
i was joined by pro-life advocate lila
rose
probably the best-known pro-life
activist in the u.s
and i was joined by mara clark founder
of the charity abortion support network
in the uk
for enabling access to abortions mainly
from countries where it's completely
illegal
now i'm calling it pro-choice in
pro-life because that's what the groups
refer to themselves as
i had people from both sides of the
debate message me saying no it should be
pro-choice versus anti-choice
or no it should be pro-abortion versus
pro-illegal abortion
or no it should be pro-life versus
pro-killing babies
these issues are very contentious the
point of this
is to hear both sides now this episode
was
spicy i got a bit flustered with lila
rose
went on a bit of a down syndrome rant so
please
don't take what i'm saying here the
wrong way i don't hate people with down
syndrome
we'll get into that later you'll see
it's contentious
it's bound to get spicy i tried to ask
similar questions to both parties and
i tried to play devil's advocate to both
and oof
lyle is a spicy tamale so it was tough
but it was so good
please tell me what you thought in the
comments but try to be civil
to everyone involved finding someone to
have a discussion with
after i got lila rose was insanely hard
so thanks a lot tamara clark
now if one of the people here on this
episode gets destroyed in the comments
the chance of this happening again
lessens it's really difficult it's
a lot of work for me to find honestly
more
left-leaning people to get on here to
participate
and i'm trying to continue this series
so be civil
this episode is brought to you by merty
creative co i have their
beautiful leather journal but they have
other handmade genuine leather
products like folios cup holders wallets
you can get it engraved for free by
using the code mp
writing is a very therapeutic experience
something i need after these podcasts
i mainly journaled when i was ill and i
actually don't do it as much anymore it
was helpful for me to get negative
thoughts out of my head
sometimes if you write them down they'll
actually leave your brain
i like their journal product the best
and you can grab it at mertycreative.co
and with code mp you can get free
engravings on their products
beautiful leather products made in the
us check out their podcast too if you're
interested in learning how to start a
small business
at mertycreative.co on youtube okay
enjoy the episode i hope you like it i
am exhausted after filming those they're
honestly stressful topics but i think i
like this format a lot
remember to check out my clips channel
at mckayla peterson clips and rate and
subscribe
i'm going to age faster if i do too many
of these episodes
okay nervously releasing the episode
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
kylo rose welcome to my podcast thanks
for having me
can we start off by you just giving my
audience if they don't know who you are
a bit of a background about who you are
and what it is that you do
sure i'd love to so i am a californian
born and raised and i'm in northern
california now
and then as a teenager i actually
started my own advocacy organization
called live action and we're now the
digital leader for the global human
rights movement of
pro-life so we educate millions of
people every week with the truth about
abortion and human dignity
and then i'm also a writer and a mom
and a wife and yeah that's kind of the
quick
the quick note on it let's start off
with simple
what is your stance on abortion um who
should be able to get it whether it
should be available
just a background of what you stand for
sure
so i will start by just sharing a story
of how i even found out about abortion
and why it became an issue for me and
then that will kind of
illustrate maybe um for maybe for some
make it more clear why
it's something i've devoted so much of
my life to working to stop
uh so when i was a young younger before
starting the organization as a teenager
i saw i found this book
called a handbook on abortion and it was
basically a guidebook for
activists who were pro-life and so my
parents were kind of pro-life but i
wasn't
strongly opinionated one way or the
other i hadn't really learned much about
the issue yet
so i remember opening the book and it
had an insert in it and in the part of
the insert there were actually
images of children in the first
trimester so this is when the
vast majority of abortions happen and as
you may know
at three and a half weeks the baby's
heart is already beating by ten weeks
you can see the fully formed
body you can see the arms and legs on
the face and i was looking at an image
actually of a baby
in the first trimester at just 10 weeks
old and
this baby had actually been torn apart
by a powerful
first trimester suction aspiration
abortion which is the most prevalent
abortion in the united states
and just looking at this baby i mean you
can see this is a human life this is a
human being i was just really
struck and i thought you know i hadn't
heard all the rhetoric of pro-choice or
all this
you know euphemistic language about
claiming that this act of violence is
empowerment i was just looking at the
fact of what an abortion does to a human
being a developing
growing human being somebody's son or
daughter and i was just struck and i
thought wow
i can't believe this is happening you
know i didn't again didn't have a lot of
information yet
and i just thought how can we how can we
allow this to happen and so that
inspired me to learn more
and i discovered and these are some of
the facts there's over today
over 2400 abortions happening every
single day in the u.s
legally and that this was positioned you
know when it was legalized in 1973 as a
somehow a woman's right and i found this
how can we see an act of violence
against another human being as somebody
else's right
you know we don't have the right to kill
an innocent human life it's never right
to intentionally take an innocent human
life and so if this is a human being in
the womb which we know
the science is crystal clear this isn't
like a non-human of course it's a human
human parents make human kids this is a
human life
then it's never right to intentionally
end that human life
whether they're in the womb or outside
of the womb
what about the what about the abortion
pills
is that a different story because you do
those earlier right
um that's also first trimester so
abortion pills are used to kill babies
between seven up to ten eleven weeks and
yeah abortion pills are just like i mean
like a suction abortion the only
difference is how they kill the baby
um it's you're still killing a child
you're still killing a human being and
they're still
they're still for that reason wrong and
they shouldn't be legal
um the way an abortion pill works is you
take two pills there's a regimen
a pill regimen the first pill is
designed to basically starve the baby of
nutrients so that the baby dies um and
it's
you know sometimes takes a day can take
hours to a day
and then the second pill forces a
miscarriage so that the baby is expelled
from the
from the mom it's basically like an
early labor so that too is an act of
violence against that child that child
was living was
was growing and you basically starved
that baby to death and then
you know obviously forced forced its
birth
okay what about the argument like how
far does this how far does this go what
about the argument that
people get pregnant by rape or by incest
or they have a
really ill baby like one that
potentially isn't going to make it
or one that's going to make it but it's
going to be really sick
so where do you stand on those issues
sure
well first of all for a baby who's
really sick i mean i would ask you you
know do you think it's ever okay to kill
you know a baby who's sick like if your
baby gets sick
if your baby is disabled if you have a
two-year-old you find out they have
cancer
or they get in a terrible car accident
and they're just you know
very disfigured or something like that
does that mean it's okay to kill them
and i think the vast majority of people
would say no you know just because
you're sick or you're disabled
or just because you might even have a
terminal illness that doesn't mean that
you should be killed by your parents
um so the same applies for a child in
the womb i mean the reality is
birth does not suddenly transfer human
humanity to you
you're human before and after birth i
mean your life didn't start at birth
michaela my life didn't start at birth
the science is clear and the biology of
claire is when it starts when our lives
start
our life starts at the moment of
fertilization and then you just need
time and nourishment to grow
unless something interrupts your growth
which could be an act of violence
against you
so if the baby's disabled that baby
deserves even more care
and what's really cool is that there's a
there's a tremendous amount of
increases in medical technology to help
children
who might have health issues or birth
defects in the womb and there's actually
pain prenatal surgery that's possible
and that is practice so
you can actually for some conditions go
in and treat the baby
in order to give that child a better
chance at outcomes after birth
and then you also mentioned um rape and
incest which we hear a lot as sort of a
justification for abortion
first of all it's important to note that
less than one percent of all abortions
are done because of rape or incest so
the vast majority of abortions are done
for basically convenience reasons for
the for the mother for the woman
um but interestingly rape and incest is
used as the justification for abortion
on demand right
that's usually what you'll hear people
say we can't make abortion illegal
because of rape and incest even though
that's less than one percent of all
abortions
um so i usually tell those people i'm
like okay so would you be okay with
making all the other abortions illegal
and typically the person's like oh no
and so i'm like well why
why do you use that as a justification
when actually you want all abortions to
be legal for any reason
um that being said rape and incest are
obviously horrific cases
you know as a woman someone who has you
know close friends who are survivors
of rape and incest um i am you know
completely
for advocating for that that girl for
that woman you know she deserves
the very best support and help and
that's one of the reasons why rape is so
disgusting and so horrible because
you're you're violencing somebody a you
know woman in such a horrible way and
that it can create a new life i mean
that's
why we should approach sex with
tremendous respect and responsibility
because it can create human life
but then do we take out the penalty of
if a pregnancy does result
do we take out the penalty of that rape
on
this child who's conceived in violence
do they get the death penalty for the
crimes of his or her father
in the u.s we don't even give the death
penalty to rapists it's actually against
federal law to give the death penalty to
rapists
so why would we give the death penalty
to a child who's conceived in rape
and when you look at women who are
survivors of rape who may get pregnant
having you know telling her oh have an
abortion encouraging her to have an
abortion
that's not going to take away the trauma
of her rape i think we we sometimes you
know because of rape is so horrific
we're like oh we just got to undo it we
just got to you know undo this
horrible thing that happened you can't
undo it it happened
it's going to require tremendous therapy
and healing and support
but an abortion is not going to heal her
of the memory of the rape it's not going
to take away the trauma
in fact it can add only more trauma
because now you're not only
she's not only a victim and a survivor
of rape but now she's going to be a
victim of an abortion herself
because she is going to be told to
commit this violent act or permit
a violent act to be done against her
child to kill that child now
and also against her body so rape is not
abortion is not the answer and we have
to do better for both
the woman and for that child who might
be conceived that way
have you heard what's happened recently
in poland probably
yeah i mean the there's a lot that is
you know
a lot of which thing are you referring
to actually
whatever happened wednesday evening i
know that there's been protests because
apparently abortion is just illegal now
there even
even the ones um caused by rape or
caused by
um serious problems with a baby
and apparently there are like people are
taken to the streets like hundreds of
thousands of people to protest as women
mainly
um that just got passed wednesday
so poland has been yeah poland has been
pro-life for
a long time and one of the few nations
that still protect children in the womb
and there has been i mean the protests
you may be seeing this last week
there have been protests you know they
ebb and they flow because
what happens is globally there's a
really powerful abortion lobby and this
actually happened in ireland a couple
years ago
it happened in argentina just last just
a few weeks ago
and what happens is this global abortion
industry so the united states is
is basically an exporter of abortion we
have this multi
that we have a billion dollar planned
parenthood corporation in our country
1.5 billion dollars which has all these
affiliate groups and their job is to
convince other countries to legalize
abortion because they're trying to grow
their industry they're trying to grow
their influence and so they send
activists to these other countries they
try to drum up support for their cause
in these countries
there's a lot of money involved in it
and in poland they're trying to do this
as well
and thankfully the polish people have
stood strong and said we're not going
just because of work just because we're
getting pressure from other countries
and just because of some of the pressure
coming from within
we're not going to allow the killing of
children in the womb just because
they're in the womb no we're not going
to allow
going to allow this human rights abuse
and so they're standing up against it so
absolutely there's going to be
counter protests to that stance but just
because a group of people
demand the right to kill doesn't mean
that doesn't mean they should be given
that right
i mean there's no right to kill an
innocent child that right doesn't exist
it's been invented
and unfortunately a whole generation of
women you know us
have been told we've been lied to we've
been told that somehow feminism equality
is permitting the killing of our of our
own children
permitting the killing of boys and girls
in the womb
you can't achieve equality we as women
cannot achieve equality
if we build a new system of oppression
against children
that's not the way to do it um we say
we're fighting the patriarchy well
there's a new
system of oppression that we are
creating and permitting now that we've
supposedly won these rights
to now step on our kids to step on human
beings in the womb and that's not the
way
to achieve equality we have to do better
and that's why
education is so important care for
mothers is so important
and so much of the other work that the
pro-life movement does day in and day
out and they are doing that work in
poland
courageously a lot of the public
movement in poland is very strong you
know
hundreds of thousands have marched the
street of poland for life so it's not
just like
you know pro-abortion people doing that
and so you know the battle goes on
because
these are two forces against each other
okay so what i heard when i was a
teenager
i think was that people who live
in countries where abortion is
completely illegal will
and decide that they're aborting this
baby no matter what
will uh go through lengths to abort the
baby and they'll end up
harming themselves and one of the
arguments for
having legalized abortion is to stop
people from getting extremely desperate
and actually damaging themselves
your thoughts on that yeah of course so
first of all
it's um it's a fact you know there's a
lot of studies that speak to this you
can
go to i'm referencing some that have
been collected at the charlotte legere
institute
uh making abortion illegal does decrease
the abortion rate
so it does deter many many women from
having abortions
when you limit abortion access less
women have them period so that's the
good news and the importance of having
laws to protect children
um the second thing is you know and in
the united states just an example the
year abortion was legalized
there was about 13 or so abortions for
every thousand women
it jumped 50 percent the very next year
it was legalized
so that's just one example of how the
abortion law
does prevent abortions from happening as
far as back alley abortions are
concerned listen abortion period is
violent
it's by nature unsafe for the child
right it kills the child every time
so in that sense there's no such thing
as a safe abortion um
and the abortion industry in the united
states which is legal still kills women
in 2012 for example tanya reeves was
left hemorrhaging to death in a planned
parenthood abortion clinic in chicago
so deaths are still happening of women
by abortion with legal abortion
and i think that you know women are
smart i don't think women should be
infantilized i think that we are strong
and that we're smart
and i i trust a lot of women to to
choose you know if abortion is illegal
and you have these
crazy back alley abortionists i trust a
lot of women to choose to
protect themselves and their baby from
that violence and i think society owes
women
the support and men owe women the
support that they need when they're
pregnant so i think the real solution is
not to legalize violence
but the real solution to women who are
in desperate situations is to actually
help them
and to alleviate the desperation that
they're in you know
uplift people out of poverty support
women get them better prenatal care
support single moms i mean
that's what we should be focusing on not
let's enable you to kill
this baby and get an abortionist to kill
your child and profit off of that
that's not the answer it's like more
reasonable day care
and just yeah access for people
that's the conversation to have exactly
not a conversation of oh
your let's kill your children and make
it convenient to kill your children i
mean that is not
that's no way to be a civilized country
or a country that cares about justice
so i've read that the majority of and it
might be slight majority
of abortions um come from people who
already have children
is that true that is true usually
i think the rate 60 of abortions
happen to women who already have one
child a lot of them are single moms
single moms with one kid and so the
reason for their abortion would
probably be what they're they don't feel
comfortable supporting
multiple children by themselves yes they
there i think there's a lot of pressures
on single moms i mean
i'm grateful i have an amazing partner
and husband but it's it's hard to be a
single mom
and so i think that you know it's a
complex issue and on the side of
actually caring for women
and saying we need to you know first of
all help the crisis of fatherlessness
i mean that's a big part of the problem
like father's abdicating their
responsibility
you know abandoning the women that they
pledge to love leaving their kids to you
know without the support that they need
um so it's that's a whole conversation
and i and i think it's when the prologue
movement has a lot we do talk a lot
about adoption foster care helping
um single moms um so it's very very
important
but again if you're using that as a
justification to say okay well they
should then
kill their second child you know to say
to a single mother
you have a heart you know you're having
a really hard time so let's
let's just enable you to kill your child
let's just make let's just deal let's
just deal with your family by killing
off one of your family members
um that's not that's no real solution
you know violence is not the solution
and so
let's work to solve her problems not
kill off that second child because
listen
if you have if you're a single mom and
you have an abortion and you have your
already two-year-old son or your you
know your young child
you're in the same exact place you were
before you were pregnant
it's not like someone came in and gave
you better job opportunities
better help with your child better
medical care you just now have a dead
child
as part of your family right so the
abortion actually doesn't solve any
problem for the single mom
it just makes her the mother of another
child who's dead now
and she still is in the exact same
circumstances she was in before so our
focus should be in solve helping solve
her problems
not seeing her child as the problem
here's here's a question so what if you
you have a couple of kids
and one of the kids is already really
sick so you spend most of your time
as a stay-at-home mom maybe you have a
partner too and you're already caring
for one kid who's
really sick and you get pregnant and you
find out that this baby has down
syndrome
and so then you have okay if i have a
baby with down syndrome i don't know if
i'm able to care for one kid who's
already chronically ill
what's the right decision according to
you in that period of time say
you find out early so you find out
within the first month
well first of all i would just ask you
michaela would you
kill a family let's say a family has a
baby with down syndrome or a
five-year-old with down syndrome
but personally like i don't think i
don't think that the
a five-year-old can be compared exactly
fairly to
two weeks post-conception like i don't
think that's
not why not because
first of all just having a miscarriage
happens around
like that can happen then and well
you're five years old because they can't
survive outside
i'm like i'm not i don't even know where
i stand on either of these issues
personally probably i don't really like
putting
my opinion on anybody um i think that
the ease
i guess i can get into this a little bit
i think that the
ease of access to abortion right now is
dangerous because
people don't understand the
ramifications of doing it even
psychologically and
if you're in a relationship you can be
pressured into it by the other person in
your relationship
so i think those are problems but i
think downright like making it
straight up illegal can be dangerous to
women i think it's a tricky subject i
don't um so
i don't know exactly where i stand with
it but probably
i don't like putting my restrictions on
anyone if they're going to make mistakes
themselves then that's on them that's
probably where i stand but
i don't think that the comparison
between a five-year-old with down
syndrome is reasonable
for two weeks post-conception especially
if this family is going through
having a really sick kid already because
then they have to go through
a pregnancy and then and then end up
doing what keep
keep their keep another arguably
chronically ill
child or put putting them up for
adoption which would just be
that'd be hard too i can see like i can
see both sides but i'm not really sure
where
to think about it which is what i how i
felt about the previous episode too
on porn yeah yeah i hear you so
first off i would say i think the
compassion is good you know we
the goal is we want to care for these
kids and their families and we want we
see people's pain and i think that's
important
but i also think um you know in seeing
people's pain we have to acknowledge
all the people involved and we can't um
pit one against the other to say
okay we can kill one off this isn't the
hunger games you know we can kill one
off
to help the others survive i don't think
that's just
i think that actually is an incredibly
unjust system
it's a complete violation of the human
rights of that one who's seen as the
weakest one so it should be
he or she should be killed off and you
mentioned well there's a big difference
between a few weeks after
you know conception or fertilization and
like a five-year-old i know you said
that
and i get why you might think that
because on its face you know
that baby at just a few weeks after
conception is so small
you know a lot of women and you
mentioned two weeks after conception
they don't even know they're pregnant a
lot of women don't even know you've got
to find out
yeah so yeah you wouldn't know so most
women they find out they're pregnant at
around six weeks lmp
seven weeks lmp um when that point the
baby's heart's already beating etc so
my point here is um i think we need to
take a step back
from sort of the rhetoric and sort of
how we've been i think trained to think
about this and look at it more
from a position of what is just and what
is logical because that's going to guide
our society to make the right decisions
and make us for us to make the right
decisions
and the question is is that down
syndrome baby at just three weeks old
from fertilization is that down syndrome
baby a human being
what would you say is it a human is that
a human
i don't know how i feel about that i
honestly don't
three weeks i don't know if i could do
it but i've also been chronically ill
and i've seen what that does to a family
and it sucks up all the energy and i
think that if you have a chronically ill
kid and then you find out you have a
chronically ill kid i think
having a government mandate that you
have to have that kid
and make your entire family go through
having another chronically ill kid just
isn't up to me to decide
but if it is a kid do you have the right
to kill kill a kid
you're calling you're calling him or her
i don't think like three weeks
i mean i guess i'm probably
jesus i don't know like i just don't
think it's my right to decide mainly
like i'm not like for me it's my right
to decide what i do
i just wouldn't want anybody else
telling me what to do even if i end up
being like no i'd keep it it's a kid
i wouldn't be i wouldn't be fair being
like i know your situation
better than you do so do what i say
but would you be comfortable say saying
yes the government should not allow
parents to kill let's say a 13 month old
baby who has down syndrome would you be
comfortable saying that like you
parents should not be able to put to
death their down syndrome
newborn would you be 100 percent okay
so what's different then in your book
why is that 13 or that newborn down
syndrome baby
more valuable to the point where he or
she should have protection of the law
than a baby a few months earlier
well a few months earlier as in like 12
months earlier
well sorry newborn it would be 24 or
22 or something let's say for a newborn
so you're a newborn down syndrome baby
let's let's walk it back
let's say you're seven months old
pre-born
and you're a down syndrome baby do you
think it's okay to kill
at that age pre-born as in
seven months before you're born not born
seven months yeah i've heard that term
um before unborn i see um
i don't think it's up to me to decide
for other people it's like i'm not going
any further than that
i don't know i don't like i don't know
you think to me like i'm not comfortable
with the government mandating really
anything really i don't think the
government's smart enough to make
major decisions for other people um and
then you say well maybe
just making abortion legal is a
government thing right
making it illegal as a government thing
so so are you saying the government
shouldn't are you saying the government
shouldn't mandate not killing your
your newborn what no
don't captain room in me i no i'm just
trying to understand where your what
your position is i think
you're it sounds like you're saying
birth is the moment that the government
should
be concerned no that's not what i'm
saying i'm saying what are you saying
three weeks i'm saying that i don't
think i have the right to put my
decision on other people
but you don't want to say that for the
newborn baby
but why let me explain what tell me why
logically
what why are you suddenly human and
suddenly it's okay for you
to be protected from being killed by
your parents when you're born
because some people still kill their
newborns but that's at least against the
law right
why is it okay to be protected when
you're
born but it's not okay to be protected
before you're burned because it was
still
you michaela like before and me before
we were born we were still
us we're just smaller so why is it okay
unless developed why is it okay to kill
i don't necessarily think it's okay
but you said you don't want to get human
right but you wouldn't
put it on somebody else but i think if
i'm hearing you correctly correct me if
i'm wrong you're saying you do think it
is your right in in a sense to impose
your opinion of yes don't kill a newborn
like if you were you know
the prime minister and you had the
ability to make the law you would make
killing your newborns
illegal right i'd probably just make
it legal to kill other people who are
doing that
that was a really terrible joke but yeah
no i don't want murder to happen
okay you don't want murder to happen
good i'm glad so we can agree on that so
then the next question is what is murder
okay
and the argument the argument between
the approach pro-choice and pro-life
it's really interesting because you talk
to somebody who's pro-choice and they're
100 for women and
pretty much zero percent for an unborn
baby
right so i'm a hundred percent for both
i'm a hundred and fifty percent for
women and children
and i don't have women two chronically
ill children like what about what about
the kids that
i think help i think we need to help
them i think we need to help
families with chronically ill children
but i don't think we should ever say
the solution to a family with two
chronically ill children is to kill one
of them
because they are smaller and less
developed so it's more convenient and
easy to kill that other child
i think that's that's the difference
between pro-life and pro-choice the
difference is
pro-life says we are 100 for women 100
for children
but if it is an innocent human life that
nothing justifies taking their life
you you can you can talk about this
really horrible situation and i'll say
let's walk into that situation that's
horrible and solve problems
let's not let's not kill we'll let we
can talk let's talk about that we can
actually have that conversation i think
that's that's the conversation to be
having
not the conversation of should we kill
off the sick sibling
because they're younger and they're in
the womb that that's not the comfort
that's
i hate that we're having that
conversation at all that's the
conversation that the pro-choice
side has us having right now michaela
instead we should be talking about okay
how do we actually care for
children with disabilities
yeah i accept it wouldn't be us caring
for the kid it would be the family that
we decided well we should try to help
families
right but we should try to help families
like that i know i think i'm just saying
like i was i was very ill and there's no
help like
i it would be better if life were easier
but you can't say
you know it's easy just to say we should
make
daycare more accessible and we should
also
i'm still not i haven't made up my mind
on what i would do
or what i think is right here i like i'm
going back to that i'm just not
comfortable with
with deciding for other people if i
don't know what their situation is
um but saying you know you can make
daycare more accessible and you can make
it easier to care for chronic children
like
that's gonna take we're all locked at
home right now like how's the government
supposed to at least in canada where i
am um how is the government supposed to
help take care of chronically ill
children and isn't that you know two or
three decades
away so what do we do in the interim
yeah
um that's a very good question and i
think we do everything we can to
push towards survive and put and yeah
move forward but
the moment you start to say okay kill
the child
that is the weakest and the smallest and
that's in my room right now because i
just can't handle it
um what are you saying you're saying
that a violent act against an innocent
human being is
is okay and i think if if you want to
live in a society like that you know
i i think you're you're you're
acknowledging yeah i'll live in a
society where human rights are violated
for the very weakest members of my
society and i'm okay with that
but i i'm not okay with that and i don't
think any of us should be okay with that
and i think deep down when we look at it
from the perspective of science and
logic we realize that even though
you know we have these like really
heartbreaking cases they do not justify
and they actually don't
they don't solve i mean you kill off a
baby with disabilities it's not like
your life gets happier and healthier and
better
i think even a child who's chronically
ill deserves to
live for as long as he or she can
naturally live even when you were
really sick michaela it's not like it
would have been better for you to have
been killed
right i mean i i can't imagine you would
say that look at you look at you now and
all you've overcome no i made it
i made it out but that's autoimmune
disorder that's not
that's like but but i mean a child is
chronically ill
a child who has down syndrome they don't
deserve that they don't deserve to be
killed and and they have a they have
so much um life that's that's valuable
even though they're sick and even though
they have a disability
i think it's extremely ableist and
discriminatory
to say to about children who are sick or
disabled you know who maybe can't come
on your podcast and defend themselves to
say oh
it's you know they should they should
it's okay to avoid them
because they're just about is also not
what i'm saying
okay all right explain tell me why
you're not saying that then
tommy's not saying abort sick children
i was a sick child it's not what i'm
saying either
i'm just saying glad to hear that yeah
well it's hard
it's hard for me to justify making
decisions for people who are
in complicated situations by saying hey
i know what i would do in your situation
because i'm a i don't know better person
maybe
um which perhaps i would make a
different choice
like i had a kid i have scarlett she's
three and a half and i had her
accidentally eight months into a
relationship when i was 24.
and it was really really rocky
but now i have a three and a half year
old and i've managed to sort out my
problems somehow
miraculously and i'm really hashed on
the
decision i made um
so i'm not saying what i would do i just
i just hate
putting i just families can have such
complicated dynamics and people can have
such trouble that
like i get where you're coming from with
it's a baby
as soon as it's a baby right so it's not
your right to kill it but
and i get that too i do
so i'm not saying kill sick sick unborn
children
i'm glad to hear that i i'm glad you're
here too
and i and yeah to clarify you're right
you're not saying kill sick unborn
children but
i think your position was at least when
we were talking about it a few minutes
ago it sounded like you were saying
it's okay i'm not going to judge if
somebody else
kills their sick unborn child well i
might even judge
perhaps i might even judge but i don't
think it's happening to me
to mandate what they do but it would be
let's say maybe not up to you because
you're not like prime minister at least
maybe not yet but you're not you know in
a position to mandate what they would or
would not do right so
we'll step away from that for a second
but the law does protect
children from getting abused by their
parents right
i would hope so yeah okay and kill sure
yeah and and killed by their parents
right
is that a question for me you yes of
course
good so why shouldn't the law protect
children from being abused or killed by
their children before birth
i think it kind of depends on what stage
i do
and i think that okay i don't just i
just don't want the government
overreaching into my life
i think it's up to you i don't want that
either i don't want the government
overreaching either but i think the
basic role of any government
is to protect base the basic human right
to live just to just to actually
not be killed by somebody you know i'm
there on the side of smaller government
too
but if i'm a sick disabled little child
and the government's not protecting me
from literally getting
torn apart whether it's in utero or
killed after birth
then i think the government is actually
rejecting its basic duty do you know
anything about the mental impact
on people after having an abortion it's
a great question so there's a lot of
international studies like the macro
data on it that shows that there's a lot
of
psychological um impact on women
negative impact on women which makes
sense when you actually walk through
what an abortion is it's killing a human
being and so and if the woman is
whether she's pressured into that or she
chooses it freely
um once you sort of have a recognition
of what actually happened like a human
being was killed
that's psychologically devastating so
you know over the last 15 years i've
been privileged
to talk to hundreds of women and
interview many of them and talk to them
about their experiences and
the common thread is um anger anger at
lies that they felt they were told about
their child and about abortion
anger at the the people who may have
pressured them um also just
total grief that they were part of this
um
and you know they had to grapple with a
lot of the
negative impact afterwards i mean some
studies say suicide rate spikes for
women after an abortion
depression spikes um a lot of addiction
can spike
and they were left to grapple with these
consequences and society was telling
them oh you are empowered
you know like you had an abortion you
practiced your choice you know good for
you
and they were left with these
devastating consequences so that's one
of the
many um just like
on injustices i think of abortion it
kills a baby but it also harms and hurts
women
and you're not going to hear that from
abortion advocates you know abortion
advocates gaslight
women and tell them that they it wasn't
a baby
you know it's your choice and i think
that's one of the biggest
deceptions today and lies that are told
that you know an abortion there's no
baby to be grieved
um and then for miscarried babies it's
like oh i'm so sorry you went through
this you know like
we come around women who miscarry but
women who have had abortions it's like
you just had a choice
and it's like there was no difference
between the baby miscarried and the baby
aborted i mean you miscarried eight
weeks you aborted eight weeks it's the
same baby
um your your feelings about that child
at that moment don't change its value
and and don't affect the long-term
psychological impact it may have on you
either
i think i just have one last question
okay which um
which i just asked at the end which is
um what's the strongest argument against
your position
if you don't have one that's fine but
that's the last question here
yeah well you mentioned rights and you
know there's basically two camps of
opposing rights
and um you know i think people use
women's rights as a justification for
abortion
right and i think that's the most sort
of persuasive um
argument for a lot of people are like
well i believe in women's rights so yeah
i guess i'm support abortion
and i would just say you know i am 100
myself for women's rights i think
women's rights are human human rights i
think as humans we have rights right
but my rights end where another person's
rights begin
so as a woman i never have the right to
kill an innocent child
even if that child's inconvenient to me
even if that child's sick even if that
child's struggling
um you know i should i i hope and pray
that woman gets support and
we should focus on trying to support her
like you said that's hard that's it's
complicated
but it's never my right to kill to solve
a problem and so
well that is i think the the argument
like i had this right to do it i would
say let's have a different vision for
women's rights ones that are
non-violent and ultimately see and see
and respect the lives of all people
well thank you very much for coming on
you're a tough cookie that was fun
that was spicy that was spicier than i
was expecting
but uh it was good caleb no thanks
thanks for letting me uh
go the logical stuff with you but i
think i i really appreciate you having
the conversation again
because it's it takes courage and i
think these are exactly the
conversations to have so
thank you mara clark welcome to my
podcast
thank you for having me can we start off
by you just giving a brief background
about
who you are and what it is that you do
sure
um i am an american who lives in england
and for the last 20 years or so i have
worked with various
grassroots organizations and charities
to
help women and pregnant people access
abortions
okay and you do you run do you run a
charity now
i do sorry yes i am the founder and
director of abortion support network
um which uh is a uk registered charity
and we help people in ireland northern
ireland the isle of man
malta gibraltar and poland access
abortions
either at home with pills pills that are
on the world health organization's
essential medicines list
or we help them travel abroad to clinics
by giving information and advice
of um you know what travel documents you
need what
what countries are easiest to get to
what clinics are least expensive
and we also provide funding towards the
cost and the whole reason we exist
is because we know that bad abortion
laws which exist in all of the countries
that we serve
bad abortion laws do not stop abortion
they just stop abortion for poor people
and we think i can't afford an abortion
should
ever be the only reason somebody becomes
a parent
and i say that as a mother and i say
that as a person of faith
and i say that as the older sister to a
younger brother with disabilities
and they say that as a human being
okay that's fair um can we can we start
off i guess with just
what's your you delved into it a little
bit there but what's your
view on abortion and accessibility
i mean for for me abortion is part
of female and
you know assigned female and whatever
you know we live in a crazy world with
all sorts of genders now
um but like basically it should all be
part of the same thing
you know periods in vitro birth control
female sexual pleasure menopause
um a birth abortion
these things are all the same women at
different points
in their in their lives but you'll
notice we don't really
talk about a lot of those things
miscarriage is another one
like you never talk about miscarriage
you don't even know
that 20 of pregnancies end in
miscarriage naturally
until you get pregnant and then they're
like don't tell anybody you're pregnant
in case
somebody goes something goes wrong and
you're like so if something goes wrong
you want me to have zero support
because it's shameful or
and it's the same with abortion either
one in three or one in four women will
have an abortion in her lifetime
so why you know next time you go out
with
six to eight friends right
two to three of them will have had an
abortion and why are we not
talking about that the same way we talk
about
literally everything else so
i think abortion needs to be part of the
spectrum of health care that is offered
people i don't
i don't think it is any different it is
something that
a woman or a pregnant person should be
able to decide to do
with unbiased medical information if it
is the right decision for her
and where appropriate in consultation
with her partner or her god or her
family or whatever
but um yeah just really matter of fact
and any other discussion ignores the
fact that any restrictions are
only hurting poor people okay can we
let's come back to that um but first
first how long do you think is
reasonable
for people to have access to an abortion
do you mean how far into weakness yeah
sure um you know
i i i hear that's that's a that's a
that's a
that's a hot button you know because uh
you know i'm i'm one of those
pro-abortion baby-hating abortion until
birth people which
in fact i am not um so abortion on
request
should simply be available
and you know most of europe has abortion
on request
until 12 or 14 weeks and then
under some circumstances after 12 or 14
weeks
and the uk has abortion on request until
24 weeks
and after 24 weeks in cases of fetal
indication
or risk the life for the health of the
pregnant woman
and i'm i'm cool with that although
i hate it because of the number of times
when we've had people
show up who've been trying to access an
abortion but have not been able to
because they live too far away from the
clinic or their abusive partner won't
let them out of the house
or um or they didn't know that they were
pregnant like
a lot of young girls and a lot of
menopausal women
are the ones who tend to present late so
for every
any time you put a legal limit i will
show you somebody that's one day over
that limit who you're going to want to
help
um the thing to remember is that over 90
of abortions happen in the first 12
weeks and the vast majority of
the other 10 percent happen quite soon
after that so the ones that happen
quite late are
are the ones where there's
there's mitigating circumstances um that
said i don't believe there need to be
mitigating circumstances
i i think that
having a baby is a massive deal and
you know when you look at the studies on
why people access abortion after 20
weeks
the top four reasons are it's a very
young girl
it's a woman who thought it was the
menopause it's somebody who's in her
escaping an abusive relationship
or it's a wanted pregnancy that becomes
unwanted
and in my experience the reasons wanted
pregnancies have become unwanted
have included something goes
catastrophically wrong with the
pregnancy
um we had a situation where the woman's
husband killed himself
she didn't feel she could afford another
child um a couple their four-year-old
developed leukemia and they were like we
think we need to focus on our
four-year-old right now
the thing is it's the limits i feel
need to be set between the doctors and
the patients and not between you and me
or you know the current or previous
president of the united states
or you know the church that's that's
what i think no doctor is going to let
somebody walk in the day before birth
and be like actually i've changed my
mind that just that's just not going to
happen that's not what doctors do
what are your thoughts on
i know that in canada and in some areas
of the states not all areas
it's very easily accessible and i know
that what i learned
in high school made an abortion seem
casual and then i've got a i've got a
three and a half year old and i kind of
i had her very early in my relationship
with
my husband now but we were eight months
in and i was like oh my god
this is really early i was 24 and i
ended up keeping her
and hooray for that but um i found that
what i was taught in high school
in canada was that it really wasn't it
wasn't that
big a deal and so i've always wondered
if
the way that people are taught about it
can put less of an emphasis on what it
is and i've heard of things like
i think it's called uh it's like ptsd
from
abortions from people who didn't realize
it would have a
as much of an impact on them so do you
think there's a risk there with
normalizing it too much
um well i would have loved to take your
sex ed class
because um i'm a little older than you i
think uh i'm pretty sure in my sex
ed class uh all they talked about was
don't do it
oh that's not what it was like in my
high school at all don't do sex
don't do sex sex is bad and also we know
for a fact that there's
quite a bit of places where they tell
you a lot of
completely debunked medical
misinformation like abortion causes
breast cancer
it doesn't abortion causes infertility
it doesn't abortion my favorite will
turn you into a pedophile
it doesn't you know there's all this
misinformation
um i think everybody should be offered
comprehensive sex education
and i think part of that sex education
should be
female sexual plan consent which i know
seems like it's
it's um i know it seems like it's off
topic hear me out
if we talk all young people that the sex
that you have
should feel good and both people should
enthusiastically participate
think of how differently all of sex and
reproduction would become
um if we if if young boys you know if
boys didn't have sex because they
thought they should and if girls didn't
have sex because they wanted boys to
like them or because they were insecure
because of peer pressure
you know um so i think i think you know
i don't think there's anybody who
doesn't realize that having an abortion
makes you not pregnant
and i don't think anybody doesn't
realize that they were pregnant with
something that would have grown into a
baby
i also know there was a study called the
turnaway study that followed many many
women
over i think it was either five or ten
years after they had an abortion
and i wish i had the exact statistic it
was i think it was 97
of the women said that they actually did
not regret the abortion
now i don't mean that abortion regret
doesn't exist
but i think if you really unpack what
was going
on that actually what i mean there are
some people who had an abortion in which
they hadn't had an abortion
not gonna deny that i'm divorced but i'm
not gonna stop other people from getting
married
despite the fact that i that i regret
getting
you know i regret my divorce i think
it's more like
um if you really talk to somebody who
regrets their abortion some of them will
say
they were forced into having an abortion
do you know what that's not pro-choice i
am against forcing people to have
abortions
you know or they'll say oh it's just i
was young and i never could have
i never could have afforded a baby um so
it's actually not the abortion it's the
circumstances
that led them to choose an abortion
and i'm i'm 100 not saying abortion is
right in every single case and we
very often hear from people who at first
they think they want an abortion
almost everybody we deal with lives in a
country where abortion is
is heavily restricted um or completely
against the
law so it's it's a different thing and
sometimes they found to find out they're
pregnant
they feel like they have no options and
they call
us and we're like well you do have
options you can continue the pregnancy
and be a parent
you can you can continue the pregnancy
and put the baby up for adoption
or you can have an abortion and here's
how you go for help for all those things
and some and sometimes they come back a
lot of them have made up their minds
before they call us
sometimes they come back to us and
they're like you know what i thought i
had no choice now i realize i have a
choice and i'm gonna keep this baby and
we're like
go for it good luck here's some
resources
you know it's just for me everything
about abortion is hypocrisy
like all so many of the arguments
against abortion are hypocrisy
there are there are some people who are
like i am completely against abortion
in all circumstances and you know what
great you know hats off to you and if
you're if you're basing that in the
religious argument
then i hope you never wear clothing of
more than two fabrics and i hope you're
ready to stone your neighbor for working
on the sabbath
um but everybody else like most people
the people who are i'm totally against
abortion
great but the number of people who've
been totally against abortion who have
been having abortion
is staggeringly high and the number of
people who've called
us who said i was totally against
abortion until until my wife got cancer
until we both lost our jobs until my
sister was raped
until my daughter was raped until my
mother needed an abortion
i was completely against abortion until
somebody i loved needed an abortion
um and even then sometimes they'll be
like right but i'm only for an abortion
for my sister those girls over there are
[ __ ]
they don't deserve abortions i deserve
an abortion because i'm a
good girl and this is where i'm like
guys but you can't pretend that abortion
doesn't happen
you just have to decide if it's gonna
happen safely or not safely and the
other thing like
there's a big misconception about who
has abortions because in fact the
majority of women who have abortions
already have at least one child
so they know what an abortion is they
they know what a pregnancy is
and they know who knows better you right
now
if you were to get pregnant tomorrow who
would you want to decide whether or not
you continued that pregnancy
me or you yeah i know that should
i i think that should be up to me yeah
um the argument the argument that people
use though
is that at the moment of conception this
is like the popular
one of the popular pro-life argument
abortion i know you know what
i'm pro-life i'm pro-your life i'm
pro-your child's life i'm from my
child's life and i'm for the life of
somebody who decides to have an abortion
i i like i see that i put up i know on
my instagram
that it was pro-life and pro-choice and
i had people
who are on both sides of the argument
message me and say that's the wrong way
of
coining it which i thought was it should
be pro-abortion and
yeah yeah yeah i know so one of the main
pro-life arguments is life begins
at conception so no matter
no matter when you do an abortion you're
taking away somebody's life that isn't
yours to take away
so what's what's the response to that i
mean
not to great
if that's what you believe but your
beliefs
end at the borders of my body
so don't push it on somebody else don't
push it on somebody else and if you
like if you if you think it's if you
think it is against god
well let god judge that woman
for choosing an abortion right and if
you think
it is murder then
change the law but it's a legal behavior
also if you are against abortion
you better you better be out there
advocating advocating for comprehensive
sex education
free and available birth control
educating everybody about consent
um oh let's let's also add to that
affordable day care
affordable child care excellent schools
for anybody who wants them
you know affordable housing like you
better be out there
creating a world in which everybody who
gets
pregnant is able to care for the
resulting
the resulting children right because
otherwise what you really need to do
is criminalize sex okay
make non-procreative sex against the law
because i can tell you every single kind
of way you can you can use birth control
and still get pregnant
i can even tell you times where people
had two kinds of birth control
and still got pregnant um people who
were told they couldn't get pregnant
who got pregnant so it's it's you know
who gets to say who this is this is this
is my whole thing like
you know you were saying like um
pro-life
and and and pro-choice and and they pit
us against each other like it's these
two extremes but actually the extremes
are on the left nobody can have an
abortion
and on the right i should probably
switch those up left and right
whatever on the right everybody has to
have an abortion
i actually think i'm in the middle i'm
saying
it's your decision you know you should
be able to talk to a medical
professional
and if you decide that now is not the
right time
for you to have a child and raise it you
know um or
if now is not the right time for you to
have another child because again
the majority of women who have abortions
have children
then that is that is your choice that's
i mean it's it's i just i never
understood how it could be
any other way and i got into this work
when i discovered that poor women did
not
have the same access to rights as as
rich women did
that rich women will always be able to
find abortions
and you know what poor women get when
they have
too many children when they're on
benefits you know it's
it's yeah i don't know and also as a
parent i don't think that
forcing somebody to have a child or
another child
is i don't think that that should be
something you force
on somebody because they had unprotected
sex or made a mistake or had a birth
control failure and don't happen to have
500
in the bank part of the argument is well
if you got pregnant in the first place
and you weren't planning on having a kid
then
it's your fault and you should carry
through with it
because you weren't being responsible um
but that kind of goes back to your
well then you might as well just ban
if you think she's not responsible it's
always her right
she's always the irresponsible one you
know you don't see them chasing after
you know
um if you think she's so responsible you
want to give her a baby
like you're you're you're a mother i'm a
mother like i don't know about you but i
think it's actually
quite a bit of responsibility um
and i and i and i don't think this idea
of motherhood is punishment
um and also the assumption that you
didn't use birth control
uh so yeah
it's to me again it's an extension let's
say i am
sexually active which you know thanks
coved
uh i hope to someday be sexually active
again
um uh you know so i
you know i use barrier with new partners
if i have a long-term partner i
you know get a marina coil or a depo
provera
or i forget these things are called
different things in different countries
you know and if if that
i might think oh wait do i hm do i
but it it's not like oh you shameful
shameful person or if you are
intoxicated one night and you and your
husband decide to have sex in the shower
without you know whatever
like i don't think i
again the other thing is over fifty
percent of pregnancies are unplanned
or unintended but fifty percent of
pregnancies don't end in abortion
so i just i feel like people
should have the right to make their own
choices
about committing to raising a human
from birth to adulthood okay
um one more one one more question that
comes to mind um do you think that
there's a risk of abortions being too
easily accessible and having women who
actually want to keep the baby
being pressured into it from
maybe boyfriends who weren't ready yeah
no 100
like and you know reproductive coercion
is a real thing
um and and it works both ways from men
who won't use birth control or sabotage
your birth control because it's really
hard to leave him if you've got one in
the belly and one on the breast
um you know and the other way around
where
um where you know so um
i know with all the clinics that we work
with the people in the clinics
are all um they go through safeguarding
training so they are
they are like honed to look into
vulnerable you know people who might be
vulnerable and we have definitely had
situations where
first of all we can tell by talking on
the phone that something's not
right like you can only talk on the
phone whispering into your mobile phone
in a back garden like
you know and they make sure when the
person comes to the clinic they
always speak to the woman by herself
always
you know even if it's like oh she
doesn't speak english i have to
translate you know what they do they get
in a translator
um and again i'm not saying that there's
this imp that there's this perfect
way of of sorting it out but we've
definitely had situations where
our clients have literally gotten on a
plane and come to another country to a
clinic
and then at the clinic we've got nicole
saying you know what
we really don't think she's made up her
mind and we're gonna send her home
to think a little more you know
so like nobody becomes an abortion
doctor to
for you know nobody becomes a women's
health doctor because they hate women
um you know we all we all want what's
best for people and i
you know especially in a u.s context the
litigious states of america
i call my native land nobody's gonna
you know and the other thing is people
are like abortion on demand you want
abortion on demand i'm like
when's the last time you called the
doctor and how long did it take you to
get an appointment
you have to make an appointment and
usually they're you know
it's not like you walk past the clinic
you walk in
and you're in the stirrups 15 minutes
later you make an appointment
they do a consultation they talk to you
about what's going on
a lot of places a lot of countries have
mandated information they have to go
through you you know they have to go
with through you
in the u.s many clinics have like
completely
ridiculous untrue information and then
they have wait periods
so you take uh for instance i think
south dakota
has one clinic and they also have a
72 hour wait period so what does that
mean
for somebody who has four kids and they
have to travel
six hours to get to the clinic and then
they have to what
travel back six hours and then travel
back 72 hours later it just
the idea that you would like there's no
world in which you wake up one day and
are like
i want an abortion you're never gonna
have that abortion that day
i thought south dakota this could be
wrong i thought south dakota made it
basically illegal to have an abortion
maybe it was north korea somewhere
uh i think well okay alabama louisiana
kentucky um there's um i think there's
now
six or seven states that have one clinic
and none of those states are
violent wow
uh can we go into briefly uh what's
happened in poland recently
yeah so poland
which uh it's funny we expend we
extended our service to poland
uh we you know so i started the charity
called abortion support network
and then a year ago december we we
joined forces with five other
activist organizations to help uh women
and pregnant people from poland get
abortions
because at the time the law there was
you could only get an abortion
in case of rape or incest in case of
fetal indication
or what is fetal medication sorry
i i live in too many countries um it's
when there's something wrong with the
baby
yeah there's something wrong with the
fetus so it could be
um and and again we're not this is
something else
there there's a lot of conflation with
the anti-abortion side
that we're talking about like um
paralympics
athletes and special olympians and
super highly functioning kids with
slight disabilities that we just want to
wipe out because we want perfect perfect
babies when in fact
what we're talking about is things like
anacephaly and edward syndrome
and severe spinal bifida and you know
all sorts of all sorts of things and um
even with that having been legal many
doctors in poland still refuse to
perform those terminations
so what then happened um in this last
october
is um after trying to further restrict
the abortion laws in poland you might
remember the black monday protests from
2016
when they yeah so that was the last time
they tried to really like
further criminalize abortion i mean it's
already pretty
criminal um they they do between 1 000
to 2000 abortions per year in poland out
of a population of 37 million people
and 98 of those abortions are done on
the grounds that there's something
wrong with defeat there's something
wrong with the fetus
um so what they did in october is they
said
yeah actually having an abortion because
there's something wrong with your fetus
is now unconstitutional and then they
publish that decision
um it'll have been hard to
to miss that there have been masses of
protests in poland between october and
now
um although you know maybe you hide from
the news like i do
um and uh you know and then they
published
they published the decision wednesday at
midnight um
and so basically that means that almost
anybody who wants an abortion in poland
has to travel for it and you know we
also work in ireland
where technically you can have an
abortion if there's something wrong with
the baby
but the way they've written the law two
doctors need to certify
that the baby will die within 28 days of
being born
now medicine is not exact what two
doctors
and we we literally had a case where a
couple
again these are wanted pregnancies a
couple had
their baby and some of the organs were
outside
of the baby's body and the baby had no
hands and feet
but it wasn't fatal it wasn't fatal
so to have an abortion they had to
travel to another country
and do you know what i wish i didn't
know i wish i didn't know
how to get fetal remains across
international lines so that people can
bury their babies
that is information i never wanted
and it's it's honestly barbaric it's
really
it's really it's it's gross now i don't
think that there is a hierarchy of
abortions i don't think that there are
good abortions
like you know there are some people who
are like well if she was raped
oh if there's something really wrong
with the baby oh in this
you know do you know what where do you
draw that line and who gets to draw it
so
but i do find that when you criminalize
these cases where these are couples with
wanted
pregnancies and they are made to feel
like criminals
criminals because they want what's best
for their unborn child right like this
is government literally saying
give birth to a baby and watch it die or
suffer
gross just gross sorry i get a little i
get a little
hat i'm not that involved in any
subject like this but i hadn't
considered the you have a really sick
kid
or baby or a fetus and it's not going to
make it and you have to travel somewhere
else and then you can't even properly
mourn afterwards
that's pretty brutal or
you can't travel because you're a
refugee
or a migrant or you've got nobody to
watch the kids
right so you can't travel and you're
walking around getting big and bigger
and everybody's coming up to you and
patting your tummy and asking you if
you've painted the nursery
gross
i've also heard that i think this is
probably something i heard as a teenager
but i heard that in places that it was
straight out illegal um no matter what
i heard that women will go through women
will end up
harming themselves in order to abort
if they get really desperate and there
are stories of people
that is 200 correct
yeah that is 200 correct now
these days we are really lucky because
now we have mifapristone and
monteprostol
otherwise known as the abortion pill
even though it's two medications
um which a lot of states use
telemedicine
to do and i think canada does as well um
and they are pills that cause a
miscarriage and
there are a number of charities
including women help women and women on
web
that will post these pills to people
living in countries with
no abortion but first you need you know
internet access and a place to receive
mail
there's also groups in latin america
where women are helping each other do
um self-administered um
but before these we started abortion
support network started in ireland in
2009 and that's before people really
knew
about these pills and yes 100
people called us and said um mother of
four
trying to figure out how to crash my car
to cause a miscarriage but not
permanently injure myself or die
a woman who took all the medicine in her
medicine cabinet a mother who'd never
done drugs in her life
who scored heroin in the hopes that the
shock to her system would cause a
miscarriage
a 16 year old who blabbed three packs of
birth control sorry
um she flagged is that you know yeah
she got three packs of birth control
pills and washed them down with a bottle
of vodka
100 or have when your boyfriend punch
you in the stuff we
we had a case not that long ago with a
woman from poland
we finally she didn't think she was
going to be able to travel
because she had a very serious medical
complication
and of course the doctors in poland were
like you shouldn't travel
and it's like but she should have a baby
she had a brain aneurysm and they're
like you can't take a flight and i'm
like but she can go through
labor like so she didn't think that she
could
she would be able and we found a doctor
in a hospital in a different part of
europe who was willing to take on this
case and when she got there
i got a call from the clinic being like
we think this woman's been beaten
because she has bruises all over her
stomach and i'm like
no you dummies oh my god
that's so awful what do you think and i
don't mean to laugh
i don't mean to laugh but it does but
duh exactly and again
the majority of women who have abortions
are
mothers you know i'm i'm young but like
i'm not i'm not young you're younger
than me um i'm you know i
i was born the same year as ro
so i was i was born in 1972. um
but i know what women did before then
and um while i don't
want to perpetuate the myth that that
illegal abortions now are
all unsafe because in fact the pills if
you can get your hands on the pills
are on the world health organization's
essential medicines list
even when taken outside of clinical
setting the fact of the matter is when
people are desperate they're desperate
okay um i'm gonna end off with a
question that i
ask at the end of any of these which is
and you don't have to answer it if you
don't have an argument but it's what's
the strongest argument against your
position
if you don't think there's one you don't
have to oh i can tell you what it is
babies
babies babies are cute and babies are
adorable
and you know like
i i get it you know i get it that people
i get it that people don't they think
they know what they would
do they think they know what they would
do
and they think that they can apply their
reason for what
i think they would do to everybody's
situation
but yeah that's that's the main that's
the main argument is is babies
having had one myself i you know i get
it
they're adorable but also since i have
one myself
i believe that it should be no one
else's right
to make somebody go through that
well thank you very much mara for coming
on thank you very pleasure
um yeah yeah these are important so
thank you very much for agreeing because
i know lots of people don't want to even
have a discussion about some of these
but i mean you're in the midst of it so
that's understandable uh if people want
to find you or find out about your
charity
where can i direct people sure we are
abortion support network on instagram
abortion support on twitter
uh i'm sure we have a facebook page and
um
but we are the abortion support network
and our website is
[Music]
dot asn.org.uk okay thank you very much
pleasure thank you to both of these
women
it's not easy to be dealing with these
kind of topics
this is life and death it requires
serious guts regardless
of what side you're on what should we do
for the next opposing views
you